we're going to the horse ride go into
the horse run to the horse ride up you
mad about something hi I'm Hannah and
I'm the world's OK's mom now if you have
kids
odds are birthdays are a big deal in
your house they're for sure a big deal
in mine I try to go all out for the kids
and do really special stuff to make them
feel loved but for the most part I'm the
one planning the parties and like how we
celebrate their birthdays they'll choose
the theme and the cake that they want
but I'm really deciding when where and
how we celebrate so I want to try
something different this year
Jackson's turning six I want him to
decide what he wants to do for his own
birthday so I'm gonna take the money
that I would have spent on his party and
give it to him to use however he wants
for his birthday
now here's hoping he doesn't choose
something like a new puppy or 250 bags
of M&Ms but you never know with kids so
let's go ask him first things first
there weren't a lot of ground rules for
this because you know you got to pick
what everyone - but he's five years old
he's a kid he doesn't quite understand
the value of a dollar or what you can
get for certain amounts of money he
doesn't know how to budget he'd gone to
lunch and he's been like don't worry mom
I got this like opens his wallet and
pulls out a dollar I'm like you're so
sweet but that's not how it works so of
course there's a little anxiety going
into this but I asked him and this is
what he said so for those of you who
don't speak kid he said he wants to go
to Legoland
now label and isn't Disney expensive but
it's expensive it's about twice as much
as I was planning to spend I've decided
that I will not rest until we figure out
how to make this work I feel like theme
park trips are something that families
save up for for a while so I wasn't
really expecting this Matt and I are
gonna spend some time sitting down and
budgeting
going over everything to see how we can
pull this off how could you say no to
that face okay so the kids are asleep
and so it's time for us to try to budget
and figure out how we're gonna make this
chair Clark there we go okay so we
figured it out so usually we spend about
250 bucks per kid per birthday party we
realized if we do this for both kids
birthdays we can swing the two day pass
to the park and on the aquarium and get
a night at the hotel Jackson really
really really wanted to bring my sister
Stella she's like his best friend and so
I remember like as a kid my parents
would let me do something with one
friend for my birthday we're gonna make
it work for her to come to we're why
it's only friends oh we did it
yeah go team Oh horrible
I'm looking I'm trying to look at the
camera yeah look what I got
are you excited I'm so excited I'm so
excited I think I'm more excited than
you are you excited for Legoland boogers
we have some boogers so Saturday morning
we decided to get up super early so we
could try to get to the park when it
opened hey we're on our way we were only
a little bit late getting out I'm very
surprised by how fast we got this done
and Matt and I have a couple little
surprises
[Applause]
we never get McDonald's so this is a big
deal if you guys ever had a hashbrown
before now not have you ever had a hash
brown before so we're in the car we're
on our way we've got McDonald's for the
kids they're super excited until about
an hour into the drive I realized
something I forgot the tickets but
luckily I had them in my inbox
so we're gonna stop at FedEx so I can
print them out
Legoland doesn't accept digital tickets
you have to like actually print it out
and show it to them and I'm not used to
that
so my god we are here we are in the park
one of my favorite parts about Leyland
by far was that it seems like it's
designed to wear your kids out we just
went and went and went all the first day
[Music]
we're ready to go on the ride you're in
Vegas now so watch my run oh my god we
just take a minute to appreciate the way
that why it runs so as a park Legoland
is a lot smaller than Disneyland but the
lines are short the rides are quick and
the height requirement is a lot shorter
pretty much for all the rides both
Jackson and Wyatt could go on them
together we're gonna go on the leg of
friend's horse ride what color horse do
you want white brown and Jackson what
color horse black I am NOT going on a
horse
why it is a little too short for a
couple of the rides so he's gonna get
his face painted so the one thing about
Legoland it's designed to sell you Legos
there are Legos everywhere everything's
made out of Legos it's amazing and it
makes you feel like you know I want to
build this I want to do this I live
sweet so one of the cool little perks of
our room was there's a big treasure
chest and in order to unlock it you need
to complete a scavenger hunt around the
lobby of the hotel we're gonna do this
scavenger hunt and it's gonna unlock the
treasure chest with a prize inside so
the kids are going around like counting
things and like it's all Legos
everywhere so we get up to the room with
the combo I'm like really anticipating
what's gonna be inside this box and we
finally open it it's like Legos
duh like why was I expecting anything
different its Legos everywhere
everything's Legos but it was really
cool that the kids each got their own
little Lego set from that treasure chest
because I was one less thing we had to
buy quick parent pro tip if you're gonna
be bringing your own cake to the hotel
you might want to bring utensils cuz I
did it I'm gonna wash their hands and a
cake with their hands which I mean we
were gonna eat the cake like there's no
other way but the prime example of how
Legoland is made for kids is upon
check-in I was notified of the kids
night club
that's every night from 6:00 to 9:00
p.m. there is a kids night club inside
of Legoland any leftover energy they had
from the day like that's where it goes
Jackson I'm gonna get that kid in dance
classes like he's just like letting the
music control his body he's going for it
and the best part of the kids club my
Chardonnay
that's right there is a bar across the
hall and they will pour your wine in a
plastic cup for you to take across and
watch your kids just get out the rest of
the energy they had left from the day so
day two since we've gotten most of the
rides done the first day Jackson wanted
to do the aquarium on the second day so
in the aquarium now the hit we got our
coffees they actually made it super kid
friendly and fun oh my gosh hello and
then the first thing you get when you
walk in is this it's so cool right off
the bat there's this really cool
jellyfish exhibit and there's this guy
feeding them and this woman explaining
all the different kinds of jellyfish and
how they eat and what they eat and stuff
like that and so I saw this tank of
jellyfish I had never seen before so I
was staring at them for a long time and
waiting for them to get fed because I
wanted to see what that looked like but
it wasn't all about 15 minutes in that I
looked down and realized that I had been
staring at a display of plastic bags at
least I'm environmentally conscious okay
so Sunday our final day we stayed until
the park closed cuz you know I'm getting
my money's worth but luckily it didn't
close that late because it's designed
for smaller children it closed at about
5:00 which was perfect for us to pack up
and leave and get home and not have
bedtime be super late because the kids
had school the next day
so by Legoland and look what we have
here
oh my god literally we haven't even been
on the road five minutes but there was
one last thing that Jackson wanted to do
before we went home so we drove through
Anaheim on the way back from San Diego
and there's this really cool place
called Anaheim packing district and they
have these bizarre deserts I guess you'd
call it a desert and it's a rice puff
that's soaked in a liquid nitrogen and
so when you put it in your mouth and
breathe out you get a lot of steam
coming out like cold air coming out and
it's really cold you can get it to come
out here No
but while the trip was super exciting
and fun it was really emotional for me
because I mean any other parent can
relate when your kid gets a year older
it's just like where did that time go
you know like I I feel like I blinked
and he's oh this is so embarrassing I
feel like I've linked in he's six and
like there was a moment at the buffet
when they brought out the cake and
everyone was singing and he looked a
little embarrassed and that it was just
like oh that's him getting bigger and
he's getting older so that I mean I
didn't vlog this but there's a lot of
history out the whole trip cuz for me
like you know as a working mom time
flies so fast and I just I was so
grateful that we were able to give them
that experience and like spend all that
time together and have that much fun
together but it's just like why why do
you screw up you know so
sorry small moment right there
so how was your birthday my date and boo
boo the best birthday ever
[Music]
thank you so that's all I got for today
and if you had a birthday that you
particularly loved or a party idea in
the comments or you can always text me
this is a real number and I love sharing
what you guys have to say so go for it
now if you'll excuse me I'm gonna go
start planning for next year's party so
you can never start too early till next
time oh gotta work on that Lego
[Music]